columnas de humo en la entrada hacia
lysychansk donde los ataques de la
artillería rusa son implacables la
ciudad de la región ucraniana del
donbass está prácticamente aislada del
mundo
aunque algunos residentes han decidido
quedarse
esta noche voy a dormir en mi sótano
tengo miedo mi barrio no ha sido muy
atacado pero aquí en el centro de la
ciudad es mucho peor intentamos seguir
con nuestras vidas a pesar de todo
los residentes no tienen agua potable
ni electricidad
dependen de la ayuda humanitaria
he venido a buscar agua para lavarme no
es agua potable pero gracias a dios al
menos tenemos esto
no es agua potable
no usamos pues veamos
unos kilómetros al este el ejército ruso
ya ha entrado en severodonezk y los
combates son intensos y rusia espera
tomar el control tanto de sb10 como de
lischinsky
vivimos en la línea del frente hay
disparos en todas las direcciones sobre
nuestras cabezas
como este no podemos hacer nada más que
confiar en dios y sin malicia
me hallo accede a llevarnos a su casa
donde cuida a su madre enferma
[Música]
no puedo ir a ninguna parte cómo puedo
irme cuando ella está así es horrible lo
que estamos pasando
por llorar estoy triste por mi madre
las tropas rusas están apenas a tres
kilómetros de distancia si consiguen
atravesar la defensa terrestre ucraniana
y si chance también se convertirá en un
campo de batalla